eh bien on sera tous nous sommes cinq
femmes de la liane la ligue
d'improvisation de lannion qu'est ce
qu'on fait nous d'improvisation tout le
temps du théâtre improvisé et on va vous
proposer de jouer un peu avec nous ce
soir pour changer le monde en a besoin
d'énergie et nous aussi on a besoin
d'énergie pour improviser là en direct
devant vous et tout va bien
alors on va vous proposer un petit jeu à
partager avec nous comme ça ça va et
chauffer tout le monde je vous propose
de vous lever et puis on va faire
quelque chose de sable on va compter
jusqu'à 10 dans ce prince à main droite
puis jusqu'à 10 avec la main gauche on
chez rocher et atteindra 9,8 et ses 6 7
8 9 10 6 7 8 à 10 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 8 6
7 8 9 8 7 6 7 4 7 6 7 3 4 6 7 3 4 5 6 3
4 6 6 3 1 2 1 2 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
michaud ok bon ben on va vous proposer
une première improvisation et pour ça on
essayait de sauver quelques mots en
rapport avec ce que vous avez entendu vu
ce soir trouve faire un thème
d'improvisation des mots des mots pardon
potion coach au aux gens chambre bleue
si vous changez jazz jazz est devant on
va faire un thème de coude le cochon le
jazzy l'huile de coude
donc pour ça pour changer le monde il
faut aussi changer un peu ses habitudes
d'avoir vous proposer de vous retourner
et de suivre cette improvisation de dos
et lorsque vous le souhaiterez la
provocation va durer deux trois minutes
lorsque vous souhaitez si vous avez
envie vous pouvez vous retourner
regarder cet espace a promis nation dans
sa halle à la 3e à la peau de chien mais
voilà ce qu'ont pu se sauver
au set je pensais tu es bon moment je
crois que c'est moi qui ai oublié fermé
l'enclos du zoning ouvre ma fille tu
c'est une bourde
ce n'est pas grave en la faire appliquer
comme ça plus tard comment sa petite
amie mais savez-vous que gaston est une
merveille de la nature
si nous laissons partir nous a bien
embêtés dow et il reviendra un jour je
l'aperçois là bas au bout du champ maman
je suis le rattrape et ne coupant trop
vite
chérie chéri j'ai une nouvelle technique
on m'a dit je fais maintenant du de la
culture nuages et on m'a dit que pour
rattraper les cochons il suffisait de
remettre un petit air de jazz
alors on va tester quand vous le jazz et
le jazz et la java sauvages à la samba
il ya du cochonnet il ya deux ans
or voilà d'aston qui regardent la home
hong kong et on vient faire un tour dans
beynat je suis tellement heureuse de te
voir le groupe en profite
tu pourrais me blesser moi je suis déjà
dans la vous il va falloir chercher que
je porte pour me nettoyer
vous me répéte rangez vos serviettes
moi je vous dis mardi je me sens bien je
me sens chez efforts mais je suis
rattrapé question maintenant ça marche
le jazz mais en fait tu casses toi le
mélomane mais oui j'ai pas de tous les
guides ou les cochons sont mélomanes
toutes les poules
il va donc suffire maintenant pour
calmer un petit peu les élevages pour
buzzman nitrates les besoins de lessive
de on va suffire de mettre un petit peu
de beaucoup de gens et moi j'ai fumé un
petit peu de cannabis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs vous espoir parce
qu'ils voulaient nous avons la chance
l'extrême chance
multipliant les déplacements la chance
d'entendre des conférences absolument
extraordinaire sur des sujets multiples
et variées et pour finir nous avons une
dernière conférence hier
rapprochez vous mesdames et messieurs
qui allait choisir sa spécialité
si je commence à question vous
personnellement individuellement comment
vous rêvez le monde
qu'est ce qui vous vient à l'esprit sans
trop réfléchir cool joyeuse qu'est ce
que vous aimeriez changer
qu'est-ce que ok madame la conférencière
c'est choisir comment changer tout de
façon cool bien bouge
je suis ravi de participer ce soir le xv
bayonnais le premier je m'appelle donc
mélanie cloutier et je suis là pour s
est excusé moi je n'ai pas bien retenu
je suis prise de poids les spécialistes
de changer évidemment j'en suis tout de
façon cool alors j'en parlais avec ma
collègue eva il suffit évidemment d'un
peu d'huile de coude un ça c'est évident
c'est évident je l'espère vous devez
conscience 1 la voiture l'avion fini le
vélo le cheval et la charrette il va
falloir changer tout toutes vos
habitudes pour devenir nettement ou
l'institut terminé tout ça coule une
question de fond c'est une réalité
alors tout ça c'est évident je vais
consulter guillaume le trou qui va
trouver en fait des musiques qui vaut
tellement nous transporter avec un petit
peu de chance de bien vivre normand pied
d'égalité
je l'écoutais il est vraiment de qualité
et effectivement nous allons aborder une
vie plus du pus coolitude quoi c'est si
c'est quand même pas compliqué quoi
c'est un effort d'imagination des
glissoires bon c'est pas compliqué
si vous faites pas défendre nous envoie
camille hautier et je peux vous dire
qu'à l'oreille
à l'époque je me répète pour moi même
sexy cool en fait non mais non mais non
non non vous n'avez rien à faire ici on
vous parle pas de coolitude là vous part
de la cool attitude
voilà vous luttez incroyable même si
c'est vous qui l'avez c'est une question
[Musique]
je
en fin de conférence une conférence
animée avec deux conférenciers donc je
voudrais que nos conférenciers non
conférencière excusez-moi se bouche les
oreilles
donc c'est une conférence vidéo vous
allez voir deux personnes qui vont
conférence à savoir de quoi ils sont
spécialistes là vous allez proposer en
fait notre premier me va être marchés
financiers ok ok ok mais pas plus
du coup nancy puis enfilez votre appel
ça c'est bien ça alors notre visa
conférencière au jeu s'est pas rasé pour
wii ont chanté principalement alors nous
venons ce soir vous parler du projet
commun que nous avons alors ça concerne
des choses que dont vous avez l'habitude
de parler mais un petit peu en douce
comme ça sauf que ce soir nous avons mis
le sujet au clair nous allons parler du
cannabis en particulier et pas seulement
voilà alors le cannabis ou nous ne nous
sommes pas présentés excusez-nous
charline du roy spécialiste en
construction en tous genres voilà et
l'adisq répond moi je m'occupe de
cultiver le cannabis pour le chauffage
mais j'ai d'autres attributions pour
vous allez découvrir dans la suite de
cette conférence
voilà donc le cannabis et bien nous
notre nouvelle invention c'est en fait
de pouvoir le
le faire penser au sein des bric des
maisons et on peut effectivement la
poussière dégagée par le cannabis qui
pousse dans les murs permet de parfois
se faire des petits joueurs
mais alors c'est une agriculture nous
allons cultivées de façon intensive
faire nous aurons besoin de nouveaux
tracteurs bien aménagé et cetera
éventuellement un dédale parfois et avec
des grands volants afin de limiter le le
moyen vous savez ce qui permet de
tourner leur montrant comment ça
s'appelle en mécanique mais on a besoin
d'un truc super moderne voilà il faut
qu'on a bien bien développer cette
culture du cannabis mais en fait on se
sent tout à fait capable de pouvoir
manger d'emporter le morceau de sa
maison méléro t on pourra faire pousser
nos briques de cannabis pour isoler la
maison au micro aux migraines et or vous
savez tous le cinquième élément et bien
ça ressemblera à ça c'est pas un poulet
rôti sera d'evry pour isoler votre
maison et maintenant c'est d'ailleurs
dans tous les bus fait de la haute
société lannionnaise vous pouvez
découvrir de la maison au cannabis mais
particulièrement recherchées d'ailleurs
je pense que tout à l'heure
enfin je ne peux rien dévoiler mais tout
à l'heure nous allons planter ses
petites bienne est justement faire de
ces choses formidables les mettre dans
la poche
et puis nous pouvons repartir chez nous
plus riches que nous sommes arrivés
voilà et pour les gens qui sont vraiment
très très très gourmand très très très
affamés vous pouvez prendre la pioche
les marteaux piqueurs attaque à lomé
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue alors pour terminer ce qui se
dit bon chic se tient l'année passée on
a suivi toutes les règles c'est bon tout
les réguler t d qui sont respectées je
crois presque parce qu'un fou mais on
est en fait on sait bienvenu surtout sur
dans la dernière conférence sur le
jazzman en fait on a tout quelque chose
de jazz pensons-nous alors pour conclure
on va vouloir aussi on va vous demander
quelques mots comment vous rêvez le
monde vraiment c'est important de savoir
comment vous pouvoir vous voyez votre
monde le monde rêvait comment qu'est ce
qu'ils vont bien l'esprit lorraine
gratitude à -30 rennes la nature
d'espérance d'accord alors le thème sera
la gratitude envers la nature et avec un
petit peu d'amour et d'espérance est
déniée suisse toujours je cours avec ma
chère et le cannabis me réveille
beaucoup
ainsi j'aime aller dans certaines
prairies naturelles et me déguiser en
chanteuse et la personne préféré deux
bons ni l'hiver hélas est inconnue
ensemble raison le monde